TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan
for The Developer
Show, and this is
your weekly update on
the coolest developer
news from Google.
Flutter Live happened
last week in London.
Flutter 1.0 was announced,
along with some partner
tools for vector animations
and continuous integration
and delivery.
Check out the links
in the description
below for our top five
highlights video, the post,
and the video playlist.
AR Core 1.6 is now available
with further improvements
to help you build more
realistic and compelling
augmented reality experiences.
Updates include better
plane boundary tracking
and several lighting
improvements in scene form.
The Android Developer
Fundamentals and Android
Advanced courses are now
available as a series
of code labs.
The links are on the post.
I have a couple of drive
updates to share with you.
First, a new version of the
Google Drive activity API
is now available within
expanded data model.
The V1 will be shut down
on December 31 of 2019
and a migration
guide is on the post.
Also the team will
be focusing solely
on expanding the
functionality for the drive
REST API, which means the
Android API will be retired
on December 6 of 2019.
A migration guide for
this is also available
and linked from its post.
The Cloud Security
Command Center
provides organization
level visibility
into assets,
vulnerabilities, and threats,
and it's now available in beta.
This release comes with
some new features, including
expanded coverage across GCP
services, expanded client
libraries, and more.
Details and screenshots
are on the post.
We recently introduced a
new device commands feature
for our Cloud IoT
Core managed service,
which provides high
frequency, low latency,
ephemeral messaging between
the cloud and IoT devices.
Details and links to get
started are on the post.
Last week, Montreal
hosted the biggest machine
learning conference of the
year, the annual conference
on neural information
processing systems.
Don't worry if you missed it.
All the work we presented
there is linked from this post.
TF ranking is a scalable
TensorFlow-based library
for learning to rank.
It provides a unified
framework that
includes a suite of state of the
art learning to rank algorithms
and supports pairwise or
listwise lost functions,
multi-item scoring, ranking
metric optimization,
and unbiased learning to rank.
More information and a
link to the GitHub repo
are on the post linked
in the description below.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
The Developer Show.
Thanks for watching and
we'll see you next week.
Vacations sound nice.
You know what vacations
usually mean to me?
Working on another work project
I haven't gotten to in a while.